تتصاعد اعداد المتظاهرين في اسرائيل
اسبوعا تلو الاخر حتى وصل عددهم ربع مليون
متظاهر في احد الاسابيع يغلقون الطرق
الرئيسيه ويشلون حركه السير ويهتفون ضد
خطه حكومه نتنياهو
سنعمل كل شيء من اجل منع التشويش على حياه
المواطنين ولن نسمح لاي احد بعمل خلل في
الديمقراطيه الاسرائيليه والغاء قرار
الاغلبيه في اسرائيل اما الحكومه
الاسرائيليه تتعامل بحزم مع هذه المظاهرات
واصدر وزير الامن القومي اعتمر بن جفير
تعليمات صارمه لفظها حيث استخدمت قنابل
الصوت وسيارات تضخ المياه وحررت بعض
المخالفات
الهدف هنا اسقاط حكومه تم انتخابها بطريقه
ديمقراطيه قبل عده اشهر والذهاب الى
انتخابات سادسه وفي سابقه هي الاولى من
نوعها ضباط وطيارون في سلاح الجو وجنود في
وحدات الاحتياط التي تشكل عمود الاساس
والكتله القتاليه الاكبر للجيش الاسرائيلي
خلال الحروب يقاطعون التدريبات العسكريه
ويقولون اذا استدعون للخدمه خلال الحرب
فلن ننفذ القرار
على ما يبدو تنتقل الثوره القضائيه الى
التمرد في الجيش وقلق متزايد من امكانيه
حدوث ازمه خطيره بمنظومه الاحتياط اذا
اصرت حكومه نتنياهو المضي قدما في
التعديلات القضائيه من امام المحكمه
العليا الاسرائيليه من القدس لان كل غاصي
العربيه